and we begin this night with the fox
news alert the disgrace former governor
of new york andrew cuomo has now
officially been charged with groping a
former aide which if convicted could
land cuomo on the sex offender registry
we have all the details coming up also a
judge is now refusing to pause new york
city's vaccine mandate for city
employees and now the fdny in new york
is preparing to close 20 percent of all
fire department companies in the city
and take 20 percent of all ambulances
offline as the mandates now are set to
take effect on monday that's not all the
nypd also bracing for a massive street
cop shortage we'll have a lot more on
this straight ahead tonight the impact
on the economy and we'll tell you what
it means for the ongoing worker shortage
and of course the supply chain issues
we've had but first we turn once again
to the islamic emirates of afghanistan
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 75
88 days since joe biden promised he
wouldn't do it 75 days since he's done
it abandoning hundreds of americans uh
thousands of green card holders our
allies our friends their family members
all left behind enemy lines by joe biden
he simply turned the page and today he
just jets off to europe leaving behind a
torrent of self-inflicted catastrophes
look at the economy it is an unmitigated
disaster slowing down to its lowest
quarterly growth since the height of the
pandemic the border an absolute
nightmare also another massive caravan
is on the way but instead of fixing this
crisis the biden administration they're
now planning to give get this
certain illegal immigrants
a whopping
450 thousand dollars illegal immigrants
this is not a joke as joe likes to say
and tonight joe's precious build back
better new green deals socialist
vision for the country it is stalled in
congress with seemingly no way out
there's no reconciliation going on even
though biden gave such an impassioned
final pitch before leaving for europe
earlier today take a look
these plans are fiscally responsible
they are fully paid for
they don't add a single penny to the
deficit
they don't raise taxes on anyone making
less than 400 000 a year
i don't want to punish anyone's success
i'm a capitalist
i want everyone to be able to if they
want to be a millionaire billionaire to
be able to seek their goal
but all i'm asking is
pay your fair share
pay your fair share
pay your fair share
what is the worst pay your fair share
pay your fair share
okay it's getting bizarre and this whole
you know i know he still uses an abacus
we have something that's actually called
a calculator it works a little bit
better
and you can't say trillions of dollars
in spending won't cost you anything
nothing keep in mind democrats have
tried this build back better new green
deal socialism you know legislation it
funds actual infrastructure we have that
you know roads bridges and tunnels
better known as biff bif and there are
now two trillion dollar bills stalled in
congress great job joe and tonight the
socialist the left-wing of the
democratic party they can't seem to come
to terms with how much of your money
they'd like to spend and how much they
want to tax you the latest draft of the
build back better proposal comes in at a
whopping 1.7 trillion dollars a lot of
that is smoke and mirrors because they
only are funding x number of years when
they really intend to do it for 10 years
the far left
buzzword of the day is equity it's
mentioned 44 times and the climate
that's mentioned a whopping 110 times
but it's just not enough for the
socialists no
they are now nine solid no's in the
house of representatives now
congresswoman corey bush said she felt
bamboozled congresswoman talib
reportedly screeched hell no and then
stormed out of a meeting aoc is also
threatening to vote no congresswoman j
paul just told reporters that there are
not enough votes to get this legislation
through the house needless to say nancy
pelosi is is very nervous don't
embarrass the president we'll get to
that in a minute biden told congress he
needed this agreement before he jetted
off to europe for this climate summit
that didn't happen now pelosi reportedly
warning of fellow democrats not to
embarrass joey while he's abroad now
while praising joe's oh this is my my
favorite moment of the day nancy pelosi
who struggles a little bit cognitively
herself nancy pelosi talking about wow
how engaged joe is and he wrote the bill
and his encyclopedic knowledge
joe biden just the same joe biden we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men and women are created by oh
you know
the thing that guy anyway pelosi was a
nervous wreck today take a look
for those who said i want to see text
the text is there
for you to review for you to complain
about for you to add to for subtract
from whatever it is we have agreement
on most of those things now when people
see the language they may say well this
goes more further than i thought i don't
know we'll see what they say back you
have to remember that we planned for 3.5
trillion dollars we were totally ready
and i say this because i feel some level
of responsibility for working everybody
so hard to be on time for september 15th
and then then
the rug was pulled out when they said
we're not going that high
but in the meantime the clock did not
stop ticking on the calendar
did i mix my metabolism or my time
frames
all right there are a few things in the
draft text pelosi is referring to 100
billion dollars universal child care 20
billion climate change 10 billion for
community health clinics 9 billion for
monthly government handouts to families
with children 5 billion for the cdc 5
billion for fleet of new electric
vehicles for the federal government 4
billion for the electric vehicles for
the post office and we can go on and on
all night now this is far from a done
deal so as pelosi likes to say they'll
probably have to pass the bill before
any of us find out what's actually in
the bill in fact earlier today pelosi
wasn't exactly eager to answer many
questions looking very uncomfortable uh
after the disaster which is that joe
biden was squashed again by the liberal
wing of his party take a look
madison speaker
are you holding an infrastructure vote
today have you made that decision
we
thought so are you holding an
infrastructure vote today are you
holding the infrastructure
oh clearly pelosi has a lot on her mind
not only does she need to secure enough
votes in the house which he's been
unable to do also democrats can't afford
to lose one single vote in the u.s
senate and right now well senator
manchin senator cinema they're still
undecided and some on the house side are
starting to revolt one democratic
congresswoman is already calling for the
two undecided senators to be ousted from
the party in the coming days we will
know one thing for sure is aoc
is the squad all talk no action in other
words are they really just swamp
creatures already to washington dc
there to get along because they like to
be called congresswoman or or senator or
whatever they happen to be
or actually socialists with a backbone
an ideology are they willing to fight
for the things they said that they were
going to fight for this is going to be
very interesting as it all unfolds but
one way or the other the good of the
country well build back better should
never see the light of day it is an
unmitigated disaster capitalism the
greatest wealth producing system ever
designed by mankind that's right you get
life liberty the pursuit of happiness
thank god we get all of these rights
from oh you know uh the thing that thing
god the creator of everything endowed by
our creator if you think supply
shortages labor shortages inflation is
bad now you wait until the federal
government spends another two trillion
dollars on their big government womb to
the tomb cradle to grave socialism add
to that the ongoing vaccine mandates
this is now about to to hit full force
and now thousands of nurses and cops and
paramedics and military personnel and
firemen emergency responders they're all
going to be out of work now it's not a
matter of vacs or don't facts they've
they've decided for whatever reason
they're willing to give up their salary
their benefits and their pension because
they believe in their decision whether
you like it or not seems like they made
up their mind in new york city alone up
to 40 percent of police officers and
firefighters might be out of a job as
soon as monday that will be an
unmitigated disaster for the city of new
york anyone actually think this is going
to make new york more safe more secure
anyone think this will make america a
better place of course not this will be
bad and according to biden's own chief
propagandist jen circle back saki our
current economic woes have nothing to do
with biden's policies no
instead according to saki the supply
chain crisis you you americans it's your
fault that's what she said take a look
what's your message to americans who are
still so worried about getting their
christmas gifts on time halloween is
this going to be happening at a fast
enough pace well so many people across
the country are purchasing more goods
online maybe some of it is from habits
that developed during the pandemic when
people weren't leaving their homes some
of it is because we've seen an economic
recovery that has been underway for the
last nine months where five million more
people are working the unemployment rate
has been cut in half and that is leading
to a massive increase in volume that's
what's happening at ports but what we
would tell people is we are addressing
and attacking the supply chain issues
even with the increased volume which is
the root cause here
jen that economic recovery is stalled
inflation is here to stay uh talk to
lauren summers maybe he can help educate
you just to recap in the wacky world of
biden your online shopping habits that's
what's causing the supply chain crisis
bill back better cost nothing was
supposed to believe that we're really
supposed to believe that joe biden the
cognitive mess that he is has
encyclopedic knowledge on anything i
don't even think he knows what day of
the week it is the world is going to end
in 10 years because of climate change
and the most important thing right now
for nancy pelosi is that no one
embarrassed joe while he's out abroad
maybe just maybe joe biden should have
stayed in washington until he got the
deal done hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else